WORLD.
I'M KIM BRUNHUBER, AND YOU'RE
WATCHING CNN "NEWSROOM".
.
>>> WE HAVE BEEN SEEING BLUE
SKIES AND BARRICADES IN
TIANANMEN SQUARE WHERE 32 YEARS
AGO, CHINESE TROOPS LAUNCHED A
BLOODY CRACKDOWN ON
PRO-DEMOCRACY WHILE THE WORLD
WATCHED IN HORROR.
THE OFFICIAL DEATH TOLL IS
AROUND 300.
MAINLAND CHINA WOULD LIKE THE
MASSACRE TO BE FORGOTTEN.
IN HONG KONG, HUNDREDS OF POLICE
HAVE BEEN SEALING OFF VICTORIA
PARK WHERE HUGE VIGILS HAVE BEEN
HELD FOR DECADES.
AUTHORITIES SAY THERE WILL BE NO
LARGE ASSEMBLIES DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC.
LAST YEAR, MANY PEOPLE DEFIED
THE BAN AND GATHERED THERE
ANYWAY.
NOW A NEW NATIONAL SECURITY LAW
MAKES IT CLEAR CHINA WILL NO
LONGER TOLERATE DEMOCRATIC
DISSENT.
FIRST TO YOU, CHRISTI.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE VIGIL
HAS BEEN CANCELED, THERE'S
PLENTY OF ACTION AT THE PARK
WHERE THE COMMEMORATION USUALLY
HAPPENS.
WHAT'S THE LATEST?
>> Reporter: KIM, I'M STANDING
OUTSIDE VICTORIA PARK ON THIS
SENSITIVE ANNIVERSARY.
300 TO 400 POLICE OFFICERS ARE
OUT IN FORCE READY TO TAKE SWIFT
ACTION AGAINST ANY UNAUTHORIZED
JUNE 4th VIGIL.
ALSO READY TO TAKE ACTION
AGAINST ANYONE WHO DARES TO
CROSS THE BARRICADES.
TWO PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ARRESTED
TODAY, INCLUDING A VIGIL
ORGANIZER WITH THE HONG KONG
ALLIANCE.
SHE WAS DETAINED FOR PUBLICIZING
IT.
FOR TWO YEARS, THEY HAVE BANNED
CITING CORONAVIRUS RESTRICTIONS.
ON THURSDAY, ONLY ONE IMPORTED
CASE -- TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS.
FROM THE SENIOR SUPERINTENDENT
OF HONG KONG ISLAND FROM THE
POLICE REASON WHY BEHIND THE
BAN.
>> POLICE HAVE REASONABLE
GROUNDS TO BELIEVE THAT THE
ACTIVITIES NOT ONLY INCREASE THE
RISK OF INFECTING COVID-19 BY
PARTICIPANTS AND OTHER PEOPLE
BUT ALSO POSE SERIOUS THREATS TO
THE LIVES AND HEALTH OF ALL
CITIZENS, JEOPARDIZING PUBLIC
SAFETY AND AFFECTING THE RIGHTS
OF OTHERS.
>> Reporter: FOR OVER 30 YEARS,
UP TO THE YEAR 2020, TENS OF
THOUSANDS, IF NOT MORE, OF HONG
KONGERS WERE GATHERED HERE TO
LIGHT THEIR CANDLES FOR WHAT
HAPPENED JUNE 4th, 1989.
A SEA OF FLICKERING LIGHT.
THOSE SCENES WILL NOT BE
REPEATED TONIGHT.
WE RECEIVED A STATEMENT FROM THE
EXILED ACTIVIST AND WHAT THIS
MEANS.
IT SAYS, QUOTE, THE GOVERNMENT
IS USING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERN OF EXCUSES TO BAN THE
VIGIL POLITICALLY.
IT'S OBVIOUS THE GOVERNMENT EVEN
TRIES TO CRIMINALIZE THE ACT OF
COMMEMORATING THE EVENT.
THE BANNING OF THE JUNE 4th
VIGIL IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
GOVERNMENT ERODING OUR FREEDOM
IN A DRASTIC WAY.
JUST LAST MONTH, HE WAS
SENTENCED TO AN ADDITIONAL 10
MONTHS IN PRISON.
DESPITE THE BAN, A NUMBER OF
HONG KONGERS PLAN TO REMEMBER
JUNE 4th IN SMALL, PRIVATE
INTIMATE WAYS, BY LIGHTING A
CANDLE AT HOME, BY ATTENDING A
VIGIL AT CHURCH OR IN THE CASE
OF IMPRESSIONED VETERAN ACTIVIST
WHO IS SERVING JAIL TIME FOR HIS
2019 PRO-DEMOCRACY PROTEST HE
PLANS TO LIGHT A CIGARETTE FROM
HIS JAIL CELL.
.
>> THANKS SO MUCH, CHRISTI.
>> Reporter: HERE THEY ARE
SEEING HUNDREDS OF NEW CASES
EMERGE EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THERE ARE RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE,
INCLUDING GATHERINGS ON THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO CAN GATHER
IN A GROUP.
AND SO AS A RESULT THERE WILL
NOT BE A LARGE-SCALE FORMAL
MEMORIAL FOR THE TIANANMAN
ANNIVERSARY.
BUT THE GOVERNMENT IS
PRONOUNCING THEY SUPPORT THE
TIANANMAN SURVIVORS AND THE
FIGHT FOR DEMOCRACY IN CHINA.
AND I SPOKE WITH ONE OF THOSE
STUDENT ACTIVISTS FROM 32 YEARS
AGO WHO HAD MANY FRIENDS AND
CLASSMATES DIE IN TIANANMEN
SQUARE TALK ABOUT THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS DAY.
.
>> BEING A SURVIVOR OF THE JUNE
4th MASSACRE, AND PARTICIPANT OF
THE 1989 STUDENT MOVEMENT, I
APPRECIATE HONG KONG PEOPLES
COMMEMORATING THE JUNE 4th
INCIDENT.
BUT THEY SAID NO TO OUR
CHALLENGE, FOR OUR DEMAND OF
FREEDOM TO THE HONG KONG PEOPLE
FOR FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY.
>> Reporter: YOU'VE SAID THE
WESTERN WORLD LOST A CITY.
.
>> YES.
WE SHOULD SEE THE WORLD MAP MORE
LIKE FREE WORLD VERSUS THE ENEMY
OF THEM.
SO IF THE WORLD IS TWO COLOR AND
THEN HONG KONG HAS JUST CHANGED
COLOR.
>> Reporter: HOW WOULD YOU
RESPOND TO THOSE WHO MIGHT THINK
THE PROTESTERS PUSHED TOO FAR?
THAT'S WHAT THE PROHIBITION CAMP
SAYS IN HONG KONG.
>> IT IS NOT MUCH DIFFERENT THAN
ACCUSING A RAPE VICTIM OF
WEARING TO EXPOSE.
YOU CANNOT BLAME THE VICTIM.
>> Reporter: IS THERE ANY HOPE
FOR THE PRO-DEMOCRACY MOVEMENT
IN HONG KONG AT THIS POINT?
>> IT IS.
THERE IS NO SUGAR COATING IT.
IT IS THE DARKEST TIME IN HONG
KONG HISTORY, I BELIEVE.
THERE IS A SILVER LINING.
I SEE IN THE LAST TWO, THREE
YEARS, U.S. LED WESTERN
DEMOCRACY, WHO ENABLED CHINESE
REGIME TO CONDUCT ALL OF THESE
MANY ATROCITIES IS COMING AROUND
A LITTLE AND REALIZED WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE AND THEN COMING TO A
POINT TO THINKING OF CHANGING
THIS FAILED CHINA POLICY.
>> Reporter: YOU LEFT CHINA 32
YEARS AGO AFTER MANY OF YOUR
FELLOW STUDENTS DIED.
NOW WE'RE SITTING HERE AT
LIBERTY SQUARE.
DO YOU WORRY ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
DEMOCRACY AFTER CHINESE MILITARY
INTIM
INTIMIDATION?
>> OF COURSE.
YOU HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
DEMOCRACY ALL THE TIME.
THAT THREAT TO TAIWAN IS
MILITARY.
POINTING AT THIS ISLAND FROM THE
SHORE OF CHINA.
THEY LIVE AND BREATHE FREEDOM.
THEY HAVE EARNED IT, AND THEY
WILL DEFEND IT.
>> Reporter: HE SWAM TO ESCAPE
THE AUTHORITIES IN THE MAINLAND.
HE ONLY HAD THE CLOTHES ON HIS
BACK WHEN HE WENT AND LIVED IN
THE UNITED STATES AND NOW LIVED
IN EXILE IN TAIWAN FOR MANY
YEARS.
INTERESTINGLY, EVEN THOUGH HE
WAS PUBLIC ENEMY NUMBER ONE OR
NUMBER TWO BACK IN THE 1989
MASSACRE, HE IN THE YEARS SINCE,
INCLUDING RECENTLY, OFFERED
HIMSELF UP FOR EXTRADITION.
HE SAID I WILL GO BACK TO THE
MAINLAND.
PUT ME IN PRISON.
CHARGE ME.
AND EVERY SINGLE TIME HE'S DONE
THAT, THE AUTHORITIES HAVE
DENIED HIS OFFER.
HE THINKS IT'S BECAUSE THEY KNOW
HIS MESSAGE WOULD BE FAR MORE
POWERFUL EVEN SITTING INSIDE A
JAIL CELL IN CHINA THAN SITTING
HERE IN TAIWAN, AN ISLAND THAT
PLANS TO CONTINUE TIANANMEN
SQUARE MEMORIALS, AFTER COVID,
AFTER TODAY'S HEAVY RAIN.
THEY SAID PEOPLE WILL FATHER
HE